this is from New York Post act your wage
is the new quiet quitting visibility
doesn't pay the bills say gen Z workers
yo the future is yours for the taking
gen Z not all of them but they are such
lazy vapid spineless and pathetic
individuals this is what your wealth
hath wrought could you imagine going to
like the greatest generation and being
like if you fight this war you will you
will make this and them being like well
that's a noble cause let's do it they're
gonna be like wow that's sad
these gen Z workers are saying
don't let them see you doing anything
and just do nothing and get paid because
you're worth it
what do you think Andrew
um is that a fair depiction money is a
human right or something like I this the
I've heard all about this this you know
the quiet quitting and I've talked about
uh with friends about people actually
working like going back to work in an
office and
um
you know I was watching uh last night
Tucker Carlson was interviewing Dana
White and he was like yeah like you know
a couple weeks after the beginning of
the pandemic everybody came back to the
office and was working in the office
and
there's there's a lot to say about
working in an office because you can
it's easier to micromanage your team
it's easier to say uh get your work done
as opposed to I'll just keep moving your
mouse like every 15 minutes while you're
you're showering and cooking and playing
with your cat you know uh it's it's
almost I think at the beginning of the
pandemic a lot of people were were
worried about losing their jobs I'm
working at home I need to show my boss
that I'm actually doing stuff now we're
having this this debate whether you
should you know work your worth or
you're working too much for for less
money it's just it's it's all ridiculous
all of this
from remember van life that was really
big yeah yeah I'm just like
uh well let me slow down there was this
woman who made two videos and got like
two million subs and they said it was an
it was a mistake in the algorithm or
something and I'm just yes I'm like it's
really convenient that there's a
movement forming telling people to sell
off all their positions and live in
squalor at a time when they're also
campaigning against climate change I'm
sorry it just doesn't sound like a
coincidence it sounds like they
intentionally prioritized talking about
how cool it is to live in a van
would it be great to have nothing I bet
the algorithm you'll own nothing and
you'll be happy and then they're like
wait where do I poop and then like this
is horrible
you have an RV and you have an RV do you
have an RV I built a van and it's got a
full functioning uh black water system
with a toilet and a shower and
everything yeah like you know a human
being like you're you know you guys you
guys have you guys have a decent amount
of income that you can do that not
everybody can uh can take a sprinter van
that's not that's not the point I'm
trying to make it I'm sorry YouTube was
promoting people giving up their
possessions to live in a van something
about it is charming though I've always
kind of had the desire to like hop in a
motorhome and tour the planet you know
in my retirement my old age or whatever
but then the realism is that it's hard
to get stuff done well here let me let
me ask you guys uh how do you feel
personally about the debate that you
know people should you know oh nothing
corporations want people to work in an
office in their space
workers either want hybrid or they want
to completely stay home and they think
that they deserve it they think that
that's yeah and and if they don't get it
they're gonna quit and they're they're
gonna quietly quit good they should they
should so and companies should be happy
if you're a corporation if you're yeah
if you're and your employees are like I
won't come to the office and be like
exactly we're letting you go and best of
luck and both parties will be very happy
in that scenario because if you're
running a company I'll tell you this
because we need this here too you want
your employees in a space to build a
culture to share ideas and help develop
I like everything that's happening in
the space so we get people hooking us up
being like I can do that job but I'll do
it remotely I say it we can't do it
and they go like well I'm looking for a
remote good luck man you know best of
luck to you we're looking for people who
want to come down and and help build
something and that means no matter what
your job is someone might be like I'm
working on this game and you could be
like oh yeah try this I'm like I didn't
think about that that's the kind of
stuff that can only happen when people
are hanging out together that are
friends that are working together to
build something you can't do these
things over slack or teams it's not the
same thing and it's an environment that
also challenges you and inspires you
when you see someone next to you working
really hard it inspires me to work even
harder so even coming here when I'm when
I'm not here I'm I take things a lot
easier but when I'm here I'm seeing
everyone work and I'm like okay I gotta
step it up I gotta you know put all my
intentions and put all my energy into
being the best version of myself as you
could clearly see I'm doing a lot of
that and and and and I'm only getting
better as time goes on because I'm
around that environment so I I think a
lot of these you know young people
they're being taught a lot of really bad
things in college and when they hit the
real world they're kind of devastated
because one they're in debt two they're
also in a situation where they're going
to have to work for a corporation or a
situation that they're not going to be
happy about so I I think this is why
we're seeing it correlated and now I'm
sorry Tim we're we're in we're about to
what nothing what are you talking about
your boots
I mean we're we're on the we're in a
recession and it's only going to get
worse and all these people that that
overpaid uh on homes paid like two
hundred thousand dollars more for a
house than it was worth they're gonna
lose their jobs and then we're gonna
have a major housing crisis so oh man
this is the crazy thing right now let me
tell you we uh you know we're we're
we're working on expansion I got good
news two of the walls at Freedom of Stan
are up on the new on the new
headquarters it's steel frame building
and paid in cash
well what do you mean you didn't take
out a mortgage yeah there you go yeah
yeah we hired a company to build a
building yes and so you basically you
pay by invoice though so they're like we
bought this then you got to pay them so
over a period of time you're you're
paying in cash it's not like you write a
check for a million dollars and hand it
to them or anything like that right but
we got two of the walls up this is
really good news the other thing is
we've been talking about doing a brick
and mortar shop and so I've been look
I've been I've been looking at various
properties the funniest thing in the
world they just raised interest rates
and all of these property owners for
some reason are convinced their
properties are worth fifty percent more
than they're worth so I go I go to this
building and they're like you know they
want x amount of money and I'm like are
you nuts like there's a labor shortage a
supply shortage we're in a recession
we're in a bear Market they just raise
interest rates they're going to raise
interest rates again and you think I'm
gonna give you that price and they go
you know what we're gonna wait what
happens two months goes by the rates go
up the price drops and I come back to
them and I say I told you what it was
worth you could have sold it I'm
inclined to offer you less but these
it's just insane right now that prices
are dropping across the board property
is popping up everywhere because rates
are going up but there are still these
people who are convinced that their
empty lot is worth millions of dollars
and it's laughable and you're like
you've been on the market for two years
I'm just you know that's that's sort of
a you know anyway behind the scenes the
kind of thing but what I want to say
right now is when it comes to these gen
Z people being like this is what the
story says from New York Post this this
woman Sarai Marie
acts out this the scene where she goes
hey Veronica I'm gonna have you take
this home and work on it tonight and
then she goes respectfully Susan I'd
rather spend time with my family
slurping an iced coffee from Starbucks
okay well look to be honest if you're a
wage worker I totally agree with that if
you're being paid by the hour and your
boss comes to you and says I want you to
take this project back home and finish
it you'll be like okay well I'll bill
you by the hour so if I'm if I'm working
for you and you're paying me hourly then
I'll say We'll commit four hours to my
home time and it's time and a half
overtime sure and then you know okay but
what they're talking about with a lot of
these young people is not wages but
salaries look I'ma tell you something
you know how he we hire here I don't
care about people who want to do a job I
care about funding people who are
already like living that life like what
I mean is somebody might be like I want
to write a book and I'm working on these
stories I'll be like okay I'm gonna give
you money to keep doing that that's what
I'm interested in somebody so instead of
being like
we want someone to do the job it's more
like do you like doing this thing you do
how would you like to get paid to do
that thing yeah I've noticed the people
that work here that that works out are
leaders like self-incline and that
you're facilitating leaders to function
in the thing that they do well when
people come and they're waiting to be
told what to do it's not the right
environment and so that's that's the
thing with these people if you ever get
somebody who's like I'm Gonna Act my
wage and quietly quit it's like okay
you're fired you know no beef I mean
we're letting you go because you clearly
don't want to be here I tell everybody
if you don't want to be here you
shouldn't be you know if you want to be
here then you know we'll make it we'll
figure it out what I identify with with
people's disgruntled uh nature right now
is hourly wages for things that can be
done like you're here for 40 hours a
week and just sit there and we'll give
you things to do through the day and I'm
like because I would get things to do
and they'd I could get them done super
fast and then I'd be like okay I'm done
and they're like well you need to be
here for six more hours and I'm like
damn this is a waste of my life I can
get things done super fast so pay me for
projects that's what I think people need
to start focusing on if you want to
please your employees is pay them per
project doesn't matter how fast they are
in fact it's better if they do it fast
and it gives them more free time that's
the thing too we don't do we don't we
don't do hourly we do all salary and so
it's like if if your job is to like
let's say move box from room a to room B
I don't care how long it takes you to do
it you did it you can leave I don't care
you know just you we got you message me
and if we need anything else this is
your task you did it go watch go play
video games whatever
like it's insane to me that you're gonna
pay me to play video games if I hire you
to paint a picture of bucko the cat and
you get that and and I'm like it's uh
you got to paint this picture and uh I
don't know how long it'll take you but
we'll pay you X and you go okay and then
an hour later it's this beautiful
Masterpiece I'd be like well here's your
pay like now you can do whatever you
want because this was the agreement
these are the terms of the contract you
know what I mean so per project like Ian
said yeah well like sort of so my I mean
maybe it's it's that these people are
looking for that kind of work right
maybe it's that these gen Z people want
the environment where they can focus on
what they want to do sometimes people
get taken advantage of like they'll be
like okay they want me to paint a
picture of bucko they do it an hour it's
done it's amazing and then the owner is
like that's fantastic now paint me
another one and you're like dude I could
have taken eight hours to do this and
then you wouldn't make me do a second
one so like it's like the important to
work you've shown your hand you know
like you I got an A plus two minutes we
know that you're a super fast person you
know I'm in it as an employer I'm gonna
take advantage of that and say well this
I know that he's going to do these this
great stuff within an hour and I'm going
to have him do like three or four of
them a day I used to get that in school
I would get all eight pluses when I was
really young and then I started to get
B's because I was just so bored with
homework I kind of didn't want to do
homework and my parents like what's
wrong you get you're an A plus student
what's wrong something's wrong I gotta
see in there you're grounded until you
until you approve your credit and I'm
like I should have just gotten B's and
C's the whole time so I stopped trying I
was like I'm just gonna phone in the
bare minimum to get through this
[ __ ] and I did and I've got
immensely successful and I had lots of
free time as a result
that was my attitude with school it's
like
the way the school fun way at school
functions is extremely detrimental to
like to to gifted kids to hard-working
kids some kids some people it's a lot
harder to learn stuff and so they're
sitting there and they're struggling so
you punish them for it which makes no
sense some kids solve the problem
instantly so you punish them for it wow
really made no sense so for like I I for
me it was it was similar I'd be in class
and they'd be like today we're going to
learn this subject in math I'd open the
book I'd look I go oh I get it and then
they'd be like do the problem I go oh
yeah it's like this and they would say
okay that's that's Monday but Tuesday
through Friday we're still doing this
Friday is the test I'll be like okay
well I don't need to pay attention to
you mumbling what you already told me so
then I'd be daydreaming or doodling and
not paying attention then the teacher
would think she caught me and be like
you answer the question and I'd answer
the question then I would get punished
because I didn't do the weird nonsense
formula they wanted because I could do
math in my head and so I was just like
at that point school is a complete waste
of time the the purpose of it clearly is
to push people into a box and compress
them
it's not making kids successful it's not
teaching them to be hard-working
individuals who can succeed it's
teaching them to not try to hold
themselves back because you'll only be
punished if you work harder which is why
I'm not surprised this is what we're
getting with the New Gen with the Next
Generation but teaching them to comply
to follow orders it zaps their
creativity and zaps away any kind of
Independence or entrepreneurial spirit
because you're not supposed to draw
outside of the lines you're supposed to
do as you're told and I think a lot of
modern education is just rinse and
repeat instead of hey let's see what
you're naturally gifted in let's see
what you're naturally talented in let's
explore those ideas let's see ways that
we could help the world rather than of
course exploit it for our own personal
benefit
and you know
this this culture this work culture is
just so weird where people feel that
they're you know that they're all that
they belong to work at home do you think
that like somebody comes out of college
has never worked in an office before it
gets a job working from home oh man and
does that person think that they're
going to be working from home until like
they retire like that they're going to
be having that they're that they're
never going to work in an office they're
like I'm this is sustainable this is
something you know this is why everybody
bought all these big houses that they
didn't really need you know uh but it's
just such a it's just the whole thing is
it's such a weird culture and uh it's
the argument the the argument to stay at
home and completely miss those
interactions and completely miss that
inspiration and stuff so it's just so
bizarre to me like I I loved going into
an office unless I had a terrible boss
what
it's probably easy to be like hey do you
want to come work for a big you know
podcast and silly comedy show and ghost
stories that's probably easy to convince
people it's a fun place to be but if
you're like working at the Cracker
Factory I can imagine you don't want to
be there you know well let's stick well
unless you're passionate about different
kind of crackers but not you know and
and that's and that's another thing uh
not everybody has the privilege to work
from home you can't be a barista and
work from a home you know unless you're
controlling some Barista robot or
something like a drone you know
which maybe you're coming sure uh but
not not everybody has a privilege so to
for for a certain for a select group of
people to be angry about having to go
back to the office think about everybody
else retail workers manufacturing
workers like they don't have that
privilege thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there